another wave of mass protests in the
sudanese capital khartoum on thursday
thousands took to the streets to express
their anger against the military which
took over power last
when year take to the streets every day
and people die every day it's not for
nothing it's for change it's for a
civilian government a democratic
government that protects the right of
people
it is our right to protest the military
will not rule us this country is
supposed to be a civilian democratic
country
protesters are also out against the
former ruling party led by president
ahmad bashir who was ousted by the
military in april 2019.
thursday marked 33 years since the coup
that he staged to grab power his party
has been disbanded after his overthrow
but protesters say the loyalists are
still in charge
the military in power now are members of
bashar's security committee all they did
was replace the figures but the former
ruling party are still in key positions
in government institutions nothing has
changed and that's why we're out
protesting we're out to overthrow the
security committee and the former ruling
party
security forces used tear gas and live
ammunition to disperse protesters
several were killed and hundreds injured
more than 100 people have died in
anti-military demonstrations the
military has repeatedly stated it will
not step down unless elections are held
or a political consensus is reached
reaching a political consensus has so
far proven to be difficult talks between
political parties facilitated by the
united nations african union and the
regional igad were boricotted by
pro-democracy groups and later suspended
and no new date has been set for its
resumption
political parties have refused to join
the talks saying they want to end the
military takeover and not enter into a
power sharing agreement
a political solution if it achieves the
aims of the street then we can be a part
of it the political process in its
current form is something we put
objective conditions on if they're not
met we can't go forward the most
important condition is the aim of the
political process if it's ending the
military takeover we can talk about the
ways otherwise we can't go ahead
but the military continues to hold on to
power provoking chaos on the streets and
hopes her transition to democracy fades
further hebel morgan al jazeera hartum